TWITTER TO FLAG THIS AND OTHER
VIDEOS FOR THEM.
SO THE MAN TARGETED GREG PRICE
JOINS US NOW A SENIOR DIGITAL
STRATEGIES AT X STRATEGIES.
GREG, HERE'S WHAT NBC SAID ABOUT
YOUR VIDEOS.
THE VIDEOS INCLUDES SLIGHT EDITS
SUCH AS CUTTING OUT THE SOUND OF
THE AUDIENCE TO MAKE IT APPEAR
AS IF HE HAD ABRUPTLY STOPPED
SPEAKING OTHERS CUT HIM OFF MID
SENTENCE TO CREATE THE
IMPRESSION THAT WHAT HE WAS
SAYING WAS NONSENSICAL.
SOUNDS LIKE WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO
ME ALL THE TIME WHEN THEY EDIT
MY STUFF.
THOUGHTS?
>> NO, SO ANYONE WHO FOLLOWS ME
ON TWITTER KNOWS I'M REALLY BIG
INTO MAKING SUPER CUTS WHICH ARE
JUST THESE SMALL LITTLE CLIPS
THAT ARE BARGE OF A LARGER VIDEO
TO MAKE A BROADER POINT.
AND THE POINT IN THIS CASE IS
THAT JOHN FETTERMAN HAD A STROKE
NOT TOO LONG AGO WHICH IS SAD WE
PRAY HIS HEALTH RECOVERS BUT HE
HAS SERIOUS ISSUES SPEAKING
ABOUT IT, OR SERIOUS ISSUES
SPEAKING.
AND WHEN YOU'RE RUNNING FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE THAT'S A
LEGITIMATE CRITICISM AS EVEN THE
WASHINGTON POST EDITOR I DON'T
BELIEVE BOARD SAID.
I'VE MADE THREE OR FOUR CLIPS OF
JOHN FETTERMAN FROM HIS RALLIES
THAT HE CAN BARELY GET THROUGH
TO THEM AND HIS HANDLERS DON'T
LET HIM SPEAK FOR VERY LONG
PERIODS OF TIME.
FOR MY LATEST ONE I GET A DM
FROM AN NBC NEWS REPORTER ASKING
ME ABOUT THE EDITS THAT I MADE
AND WHY I DID THEM ABOUT THE
SUPER CUT.
HE DMED ME ANOTHER VIDEO THAT I
REPOSTED FROM A DIFFERENT
ACCOUNT THAT CUT OUT THE
AUDIENCE CLAPPING IN IT
BASICALLY TO CLAIM THAT THAT WAS
DOCTORED AND MADE HIS SPEECH
ISSUES LOOK WORSE THAN THEY
WERE.
IN MY HEAD I WAS THINKING TO
MYSELF HE'S PROBABLY WRITING A
STUPID ARTICLE ABOUT HOW
REPUBLICANS ARE BEING MEAN TO
JOHN FETTERMAN AND THEN PUBLICS
IT AND ACCUSES ME OF DOCTOR
ORGANIZE THE VIDEO NOT
SELECTIVELY EDITING OR TAKING
OUT OF CONTEST BUT DOCTORING
THEM AS IF I HAD DEEP FAKED THEM
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE JOHN
FETTERMAN HAD WORSE SPEECH
ISSUES THAN HE ACTUALLY DOES T
WAY I THOUGHT JOURNALISM IS
SUPPOSED TO WORK THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO CHALLENGE POWERFUL
PEOPLE AND POWERFUL INSTITUTIONS
IN AMERICA.
BUT IN THIS CASE, THIS NBC NEWS
REPORTER IS ACCUSING ME OF
DOCTORING VIDEO AND THEN GOING
TO BIG TECH COMPANIES ASKING
THEM TO CENSOR ME THE HOLY
ALLIANCE BETWEEN MEDIA AND BIG
TECH.
INSTEAD OF ASKING WHY JOHN
FETTERMAN'S HANDLERS ARE NOT
LETTING HIM SPEAK FOR LIKE ONLY
SHORT TIMES THEY'RE ACCUSING ME
OF DOCTORING THE VIDEOS AND
TRYING TO CENSOR ME.
>> Laura: GREG, IN THE LAST HOUR
ON MSNBC, FETTERMAN WAS ACTUALLY
ASKED ABOUT THIS.
>> THERE ARE VIRAL VIDEOS,
MASH-UPS OF YOUR I THINK
COGNITIVE OR VOCAL ERRORS,
THINGS THAT THEY THINK SUGGEST
COGNITIVE DECLINE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PENNSYLVANIA
VOTERS WHO SEE SOME OF THIS
STUFF ON THE INTERNET WHO HEAR
THE ADS FROM DR. OZ'S CAMP AND
ARE WORRIED ABOUT YOUR FITNESS
FROM OFFICE.
>> I'M GOING TO ACTUALLY FIT THE
SENIOR IN.
I JUST TOOK A TEST, I THINK IT
WAS YESTERDAY, THAT CONFIRMED
THAT I'M ABSOLUTELY FULLY
FUNCTIONING AND IN THE RANGE AS
WELL, TOO.
THE ONE SIDE THAT WANTS TO TRY
TO LIE ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: RESPONSE?
>> MY RESPONSE TO THAT IS JUST
PROVE IT.
DEBATE DR. OZ.
>> Laura: WITHOUT CONDITIONS AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET DO THAT IN A
MOMENT.
>> DEBATE DR. OZ AT A TIME
SOONER THAN TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
>> Laura: WE REACHED OUT TO
FETTERMAN AND HIS CAMPAIGN THEY
DIDN'T RESPOND ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE BUT DID TELL
NBC THAT IT IS DR. OZ'S MAGA
ALLIES DECEPTIVELY EDITING
VIDEOS OF HIM SEEMING TO MOCK
HIM.
>> I THINK IT'S SAD THEY'RE
TRYING TO POOL THE WOOL OVER THE
EYES OF PENNSYLVANIA VOTERS AND
ACT LIKE THIS MAN IS A LOT
HEALTHIER THAN HE IS WHICH AGAIN
THE WASHINGTON POST EDITORIAL
BOARD CALLED THEM OUT FOR.
FORGET HIS HEALTH ISSUES THIS
GUY HAS BAD IDEAS THAT WOULD BE
BAD FOR PENNSYLVANIA AND THE
COUNTRY AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
PULL THE SAME PLAY BOOK THAT
THEY DID WITH JOE BIDEN BY
ESSENTIALLY KEEPING HIM IN THE
BASEMENT AND TRYING TO CONVINCE
PENNSYLVANIA VOTERS WHAT'S THE
WORST THIS GUY COULD DO?
THIS GUY WANTS TO RELEASE
ONE-THIRD OF PRISONERS FROM
PRISON.
HE HAS A LOT OF TERRIBLE IDEAS
AND IF HE GETS E ELECTRICED HE'S